today's big data applications tend to
have a very common data problem while
they all have the tools they need to
manage volumes of information they still
lack the ability to generate insight
from that data and with traditional
databases this is pretty tricky legacy
relational database management systems
are great at managing lists of items but
cumbersome for defining how they relate
to each other eventually they realize
that the relationships between data
points matter more than the individual
points themselves this is where neo4j
comes in it's a graph database meaning
that relationships between items are a
first-class citizen
allowing it to help you generate
valuable insights about your data while
also remaining flexible when expanding a
data model or conforming to changing
business needs graph is a core
technology that powers hundreds of
different use cases from real-time
recommendations to fraud detection to
Network and IT operations master data
management and more on the technical
side neo4j fits along with any microt
services you may develop can be used
with neo4j as bloom visualization or as
a store for graph QL based applications
analytic services or any other app
deployed in a kubernetes easily and here
at neo4j we love kubernetes we provide
docker containers allowing customers to
run in a clustered setup for query
scalability but we found that customers
quickly ran into problems when the
containers proliferate thankfully
kubernetes solves the orchestration
problem with less work for you
kubernetes has many advantages for
improving operations but it can be
challenging for new users to set up this
is why a neo4j leverages google
kubernetes engine gke is the best form
of managed kubernetes that allows our
customers to focus on the business
applications of their graph and not be
concerned with cluster provisioning and
maintenance and with GCP marketplace you
can go from zero to a working clustered
graph database in less than five minutes
simply choose the neo4j solution fill in
some data and get moving it's a fast and
easy way for you to get started
GCP marketplace is great because it gets
you kick-started with a working set up
tailored to best practices quickly while
still allowing power users access to the
underlying resources so you can always
customize to your deployment needs
and it also lets users track neo4j
deployments as a single unified app in
our kubernetes cluster instead of just a
bunch of interrelated containers google
kubernetes engine combined with GCP
marketplace provide best-in-class
services for our neo4j users it lets you
get up and running fast so you can focus
on your data and extracting the value
from that rather than all of the work of
setting up and managing your database
clusters if you'd like to know more
check out the links in the description
below and feel free to reach out with
any questions or comments you may have
thanks for watching
you